foreign
welcome back to the Dark Horse podcast
live stream number 166 q a segment we
had a technical issue hopefully it is
cured we will find out here momentarily
if you are able to hear us or if we just
seem to be
silent
talking but not hearable heads on the
screen yeah
our producer has uh in a fit a peek gone
to a different hemisphere yes
probably not to get away from us but
it's very hard to be certain hard to
know very hard to be certain yeah uh all
right we are audible okay so excellent
let's get on with the uh the Q a let us
get on with it indeed uh what I wanted
to say what I was saying at the point
that we discovered that no one could
hear us uh was I wanted to say what I
said at the bottom of the last hour uh
which is that we've got a bunch of new
stuff on our store at um gosh it must be
dark horse store
a lot of pins and uh other goodies no
needles no we do not sell needles so I
don't know why you said that pins and
noodles I know why you said it but I
don't know why you said it oh all right
well I don't know I was just going with
it pins and noodles yes we also don't
sell noodles but if you have any ideas
for noodles uh we'll think pool noodles
Dark Horse branded pool noodles uh
that'd be a thin pool absolutely why not
pins and noodles sure all right okay uh
we don't have those we do have pins not
pens
and noodles pens and noodles yeah
they're good yeah we worked our way
there found it found it okay uh
yeah
yeah okay so this is the first time I've
done a q a in three weeks so we've got
um a few questions from the Discord uh
let's do two of them uh they sent us
three but I'm just gonna pick two of
them here and and then before we get
into the questions from you guys uh who
are not on the Discord server uh Discord
if you're on our patreons you can access
the Discord and every week they vote on
their the question that they most want
us to start off our q a with so we're
going to start
there as we always do but then you can
ask questions at darkhorsesmissions.com
so
from the Discord question one of two
in a prior product in a prior podcast
you hypothesized that if Spike shutting
is real Spike might be a prion Dr Peter
McCullough recently authored a paper
exploring just that paper I have not
seen and suggested the resulting
amyloidosis plays a role in symptoms
doctor oh boy ethericia pretorius and
many others have also published
extensive evidence for this model if
Spike is a prion how much do we need to
rethink
boy I don't I'm I'm out of my death here
I don't know uh I would say I haven't
read this I would say a lot and for
those of you who are not clear on why
this would be a fundamentally different
thing a prion is a
transmissible folding in the case of
prion diseases a transmissible
misfolding of proteins
um the most famous example would be mad
cow disease
um but in any case the reason that it
would matter and fundamentally alter our
understanding
is that if Spike in and of itself is a
prion or a contagious folding then
[Music]
dosage
is potentially much less relevant a tiny
number of molecules could cause a
significant pathology
by transmitting a folding error into a
system
and so that's why I said that if
shedding was a real issue
it would potentially imply a prion
disease because the amount of Spike
the amount of
um shedding of anything from the vaccine
should be tiny compared to what the
person who was injected had been exposed
to and therefore if it was a significant
pathology it suggests some kind of an
amplifier yes
good
whether that's whether that's Spike or
or uh
um
the MRNA inducing something with a
misfolding right
okay well helping us welcome spring soon
here is Fairfax
he seems to dig spring our epic Tabby
yeah yeah he does as he should
okay multi-part question this as the
second question from the Discord this
week
what is to be done with modern medicine
aside from long-standing Pharma capture
we also have rapidly accelerating
medical lysenchoism from the race and
gender crowd so is it a lost cause like
the humanities after Decades of
malignment is naturopathy the way
so naturopathy isn't the only
alternative to so-called you know um
you know modern Western medicine is
broadly referred to often as allopathy
allopathic medicine and there are lots
of other kinds of of
pathies just not what they say but
naturopathy being one osteopathy being
another but also non-western approaches
um being many others and of course there
are varying
like healing modalities that don't
necessarily constitute entire medical
practices but uh you know somatic
Bodywork somatic work on on the body
which doesn't address things necessarily
like a broken bone
but can be more effective in dealing
with chronic or soft tissue damage than
a lot of what allopathic medicine has to
offer are are also extraordinary I have
worked with
um osteopaths and naturopaths have found
much to recommend in both for me and it
may just be because of the particular
um
um person that I found there's uh I I I
find
osteopathy to be an extraordinary
alternative to allopathy in terms of the
uh the combining of a very analytical
scientific approach with a um
evaluing of the human senses and
specifically touch you know hands long
periods of hands on the body in order to
assess where there is where there are
things that need to be aligned fixed
treated uh is seems to me to be a far
better if a far better
healing modality than listening to
someone tell you what they think they're
feeling for a few minutes and then
prescribing a drug or treatment as a
result which is the typical model in
allopathy at this point
yeah I osteopathy is fascinating
um it seems to
trade on the idea that there is a
neglected system of calibrations through
the body
that can be activated and recalibrated
um and it's amazing how many things it
seems to be connected to yeah as for
what to do with
[Music]
um
medicine
generally I think there are really two
things that have to happen
one is there needs to be a triage phase
in which we throw out all of the things
that misled us right the drug happy
Pharma captured version of medicine has
been a disaster and it's created a
tremendous amount of theatrogenic harm
um and you know the fact is the people
who are administering the stuff did go
to medical school right they do know
where the major organs are located and
basically what they do
and they have studied whatever skills
you know you can't very well have your
Gardener you know Sub in for your
surgeon right your surgeon knows how to
do surgery but they may have been
induced into believing that uh
treatments which are more harmful than
they are valuable are the way to go so
anyway we need a reboot in which we look
skeptically at everything that we have
come to believe recently in medicine and
reevaluate it with a proper
understanding of chesterton's fence and
the precautionary principle those being
two sides of the same coin
proper appreciation for
unintended consequences and
then we need a longer term fix for the
uh
non-evolutionary in some cases the
anti-evolutionary approach of the
training that doctors get right so we're
talking about a couple of generations
down the road for a system that's really
good but it can be a hell of a lot
better tomorrow if we simply you know
throw the money changers out of the
medical school
and get back to basics yeah I think
there's also my
my finite experience with the
non-allopathic medical
systems osteopathy
naturopathy acupuncture various
um somatic
treatments
one of the things that I think they have
in common that very much allopathic
medicine doesn't is a humility is an
understanding that they don't know
everything
and it is of course a stereotype but I
think very often an apt stereotype that
allopathic medicine as a system an
allopathic medical providers as
individual doctors
often have a an ego about them uh that
uh
that suggests that we've got it all
figured out we got this we know you
don't have to worry you the patient
don't have to worry about this we know
you don't need to know and don't worry
about it we have this handled and one of
you know I think I've said this before
on here but
even you know obviously we didn't go to
medical school but
um I you did a little bit of this but I
did a lot of teaching of pre-meds both
when we were in grad school and to some
degree when we were professors because I
taught comparative Anatomy labs and
um you know I never did humans but we
did sharks and cats and salamanders and
such and you know a lot of pre-meds go
through comparative Anatomy labs and I
remember when I first started teaching
comparative Anatomy labs and the early
mid 90s
uh there was no focus at all on fascia
like you knew you know it was there uh
and you know when you were dissecting
cats sorry don't listen
um
uh and like okay you have to cut through
the fascia to get to the skeletal muscle
and the skeletal muscle that we're going
to be paying attention to here
um but it was just sort of like oh it's
just a sheath that just like
undifferentiated muscle yeah who cares
right and to some degree that was an
artifact of like well you're dealing
with with cadavers in that case feline
cadavers and uh and it there was nothing
much to be learned at the level of what
we were doing but it also just there was
a sense of like ah it doesn't really
matter and in the
gosh I guess almost 30 years that have
elapsed since then uh the focus on
fascia that I have seen uh emerge in
many of these other healing Traditions
uh is extraordinary and it's really
completely clear that especially I think
I think across a lot of problems but
especially as you age the idea that
keeping your fascia elastic and you know
pliable over your skeletal muscle but
and elastic relative to itself is one of
the absolute keys to flexibility and to
keeping your Mobility as as you get
older and that is something that as far
as I can tell allopathic medicine was
paying no attention to and it's not like
we're talking about the Dark Ages right
this this was this was not very long ago
so
what else don't we know you know what
else is being ignored or overlooked or
just not you know just ah yeah we know
that's there but we're certain that's
not important or interesting I think
that the non-allopathic Traditions are
much more likely to say Yep this is what
we think now
and that could change which is frankly
what you do in science and if Western
Medicine of allopathic medicine isn't
doing that then that tells you something
right away about them having a
non-scientific approach
so in some sense you're saying that the
anti-fascists had too much power in
medicine
and that it is uh only with time that we
have recognized their error which
I would concur
um sorry it had to be said you know it
had to be said yes not sorry no I'm not
sorry no but that needed to also be said
that I was sorry even though I wasn't
um
I would also just point out though like
the uh the elephant in the room is the
cat dude
no no I'm speaking metaphorically oh
okay okay um the elephant in the room is
uh Homeopathy which
um I think is about to have its day
because
um
it does very little harm and to the
degree that medicine has gone Bonkers
and does all kinds of things that do
harm right they first Do no harm Do no
harm we'd be better off with a lot of
home a homeopathic uh doctors or
whatever they are
um I don't I don't know if they're
I don't know if they're a practitioners
dedicated to Homeopathy but they're not
like there are a lot of people in the
sort of alternative space who included
in their Suite of
treatments treatments right
um yes so anyway this is
all been around about way of pointing
out that if you have a methodology that
has nothing to it because you've diluted
things down to the point where they
don't actually exist in your in your
sample then that's better than poisoning
people right it's better than poisoning
people that our medicine has gone so far
off the rails that not poisoning people
uh May indeed be a a medical Insight at
this point
wow yeah that is that is kind of where
we are okay so for this next one Fairfax
is going to read the question all right
I'm looking forward to seeing that no I
think he's falling asleep no
okay uh let me just refresh this
cool this again from
darkhorsesmissions.com this is where
we're reading questions from now
question for Brett
I live in Florida and I'm glad to see
you as a member of the group
investigating the coveted vaccine harm
and malfeasance
question mark is there anything you can
share in progress or your outlook on
whether the investigation will bear
fruit is this a legitimate Endeavor in
your view
um I'm thinking about whether or not I
am constrained in this case I don't
think I am constrained because
um
there are various Sunshine laws right
and the idea is there is a desire and I
think an understandable one not to have
um members of the committee talking
about committee business where the
public doesn't have access
but
um in this case
we are talking where the public has full
access also there's only one member of
the committee here right I'm not yeah
I'm not I'm to be honest with you I'm a
little vague but I think we're in safe
territory here for a couple different
reasons I do think that the committee is
a legitimate exercise what we saw in our
last meeting is that there is which was
this last week yep there's a diversity
of opinion on the committee and that the
interaction between people of different
perspectives is welcomed uh so anyway
what I have the sense is that this is
not a PR exercise
this is an actual uh attempt to correct
for the distortions in the medical
wisdom that have come from
from corruption and from capture and
from the emergent narrative control that
we've seen throughout the pandemic and
I'm very hopeful about it
um
so anyway yeah it's uh I like everybody
on the committee and I think I think our
meeting last week was productive and I
hope they continue
can you say anything more specific to
the question of whether
um you think it will bear fruit
well there's a question you know there's
a couple different questions what tree
are you like what kind of fruit the
purpose is to provide Floridians with an
improved model of
the disease and the potential remedies
so that policy can be better made in
Florida it will it produce fruit at that
level almost certainly
in Florida model how this should
properly be done
uh then
uh yes of course it can and to the
extent that will anybody listen to that
well I think people will listen and
um you know there is this idea it is a
fraught idea but the founders of the
United States believed in a laboratory
of the states in fact I believe
Jefferson may have used that phrase
with the laboratory of the states allows
for different states to have different
policy and for us to discover what
actually works and so to the extent that
we have had a bunch of States Marching
In lockstep that's a problem to the
extent that we have a small number of
examples of Nations that have behaved
differently and had different
consequences that's useful and we could
do the same thing within the United
States and Florida is leading the way so
anyway yeah I think I think the
potential upside is is huge and I'm
looking forward to seeing how it works
awesome
okay well I've now moved out of the way
so that everyone could see Maddie but
she has tucked her head down yes she has
first Sleepy Dog all right next question
sorry
rolling things on carpet it's not so
easy
hypothesis
a contrarian position works
When government only acts in corrupt
ways
covid trans Dei Twitter files fouchie
emails Ukraine ellipses Dot
um I agree with this to a point
contrarianism will get you to skepticism
and to the extent that your government
is captured or Worse right is in that
third tier contrarianism doesn't get you
to skepticism
contrarianism gets you to a reflexive
skepticism of official dumb I don't
know
have used
these words
differently I mean maybe maybe I he's
gonna you're gonna have him typing
things on my computer I would never do
that um
I I don't I don't agree with this
framing I think well I think you know
reflexive agreement reflexive
disagreement are both
um are both static positions
and skepticism is with regard to if the
authority says X I always do Y and Y has
opposite valence in the case of um you
know
Faith versus contrarianism but
skepticism says
I don't take what the authorities said
as a uh as a directive in terms of what
I believe
well
I think we're Tangled Up in two things
you and I are sensitive to having been
accused of contrarianism which is not
how we ended up where we are right so we
don't like the label on the other hand
it is interesting that I think
without exception or certainly nearly
without exception
the inverse of what the CDC recommended
that you should do is what you should
have done
they wanted to lock you indoors you
should have gone Outdoors right and so
that's you know that's consistent with
you know this the hypothesis that being
a contrarian will work if you have full
Corruption of a system right but that is
not but but it's not the same thing as
you know it's easier like if you've got
a fully corrupt system just as if you've
had if if you have a fully non-corrupt
system simply saying yep I'm going with
that thing awesome that works it's easy
you don't have to spend much bandwidth
on it you can devote your energy to
something else similarly if you know
what it's just corrupt I'm just going to
always do the opposite it's simpler you
don't have to think about it too much
but it's obviously always risky because
you know what if the corruption isn't as
perfect as you thought or what if the
you know Perfection isn't as perfect as
you thought right so so you know what I
was going to argue they're very
different ways of going about assessing
the world yeah I'm not defending in any
way contrarianism as a mode I'm just
saying in this case you do have
completely captured and Beyond
governmental failure and doing the
inverse would actually have worked right
but the problem is how do you know where
you are with respect to how pathological
your your governmental system is right
you don't so you have to do the logic
well but
um you know from the point of view of
this person's proposal
in a completely captured system where
something has gamed the apparatus and is
getting it to work against the Public's
interest in the interest of something
private then
um it you know
it's the family dog with rabies right
Your Instinct with your family dog is to
snuggle with it and pet it your instinct
when your family dog has rabies is uh to
kill it right and they're inverse so
again
I also I resent the argument that we got
where we ended up through contrarianism
because that's not what happened but
from the point of view of the question
askers perspective
um I think they're formally right in
this case yeah I mean I wasn't I wasn't
trying to respond to to
how we got where we were going I just I
don't like I don't like to ever see the
conflation of
um
contrarianism with skepticism and I
think I think that this
Works hypothesis a contrarian position
works when government only acts in
corrupt ways
but for the fact that things change
right like static positions work and
static universes
and
um a a strategy that is static can only
continue to be an appropriate strategy
for as long as the thing that it's the
environment that it's acting on has not
changed and uh you know is
even asking okay well it's corrupt well
what if you've got two different
corrupt arms of a thing that are vying
with one another and they're going to
manifest in slightly different ways you
know the I
cannot imagine being
confident walking around the world going
you know what I've just decided that I
don't trust anything that comes out of
that and that is my solution no I'm not
listening to you I don't care what
they're saying now I just never listen
to X any more than I can imagine
responding and going like oh I just I
always listen to that guy because I know
that you know that's the authority that
I've learned to trust and I'm always
going to trust yeah well we we have done
this
um
properly the distinction we have drawn
is between skepticism and cynicism and
contrarianism is cynical right it is
reflexive and therefore has no capacity
for nuance and you know well what if
you're you know reflexively skeptical
good that's the way science works right
um reflexively skeptical because because
it requires assessment yes because
because cynicism and faith that require
assessment yes
um
reflexively analytical is not you know
it's not a simple reflex the point is
it's a reflex to do something with
nuance and capacity and all of that so
anyway well in the end where we arrive
is the same place that katrianism will
work you know in the case that you have
an upside down something but it is never
a substitute for a proper skepticism
um carefully applied
is sexual selection a mechanism for
defining the protect the productive
boundaries between conservatism and
progressivism
wait wait wait wait wait try it again
that wasn't the end of the question
either
you want me to start over yeah okay
is sexual selection a mechanism for
defining the productive boundaries
between conservatism and progressivism
at the tropics sexual selection must be
more conservative because more random
mutation you be light therefore more
species
uh no this is a this is a complex puzzle
which at some point
I'm going to return to carefully but the
idea of well so you in this case unlike
the homosexual
evolution of homosexuality case where
you keep on promising it and it's not
actually out there in the world
you do have a chapter of your
dissertation on on the question with
regard to
um the tropics and sexual selection or
maybe even two chapters I had to and the
department of Confederate one forced
onto my committee who then forced me to
remove I was allowed the sexual
selection piece is gone uh yes it is
cryptically alluded to in the other
chapter but um but anyway I had a
chapter on exactly this topic
um I certainly do have a chapter on the
latitudinal diversity gradient and other
diversity gradients and what causes them
which I think is robust suffice it to
say
uh the idea of Greater mutation rate
isn't where this goes this is a lot more
about selection and adaptation and um
non-obvious patterns of selectivity by
mates especially females but that um
the assumption that it's about more
light more mutation right that is that
exists in the literature that that has
been proposed by people it's not that
that came out of it's not that that's a
terrible idea that has you know long
since been uh debunked I think you know
you have debunked no I think uh it is an
idea that has been proposed multiple
times whether it's light or whether it's
temperature
productivity as a result of of the
higher um breath light and it just
doesn't it just doesn't stand up yeah
um but but
do the first part of the question
um defining the productive boundaries
around conservatism versus progressivism
so this is like sexual selection I
believe a I believe you have a couple of
driving forces that look similar and are
um
actually
they are
each other's inverse one is in space and
one is in time but I'm not gonna explore
them here it has to be done carefully
with the evidence uh so suffice it to
say they are about delineating
boundaries boundaries of what is the
question and it's not progressivism
versus conservatism
but I mean if you take the uh
the human political edge off of those
words and say there's a tension between
keeping what works and
um and engaging with variability such
that you can withstand the changes that
are to come or that have already come
since you the parents existed then
they're like that that begins to be an
accurate description of some of the
tensions that exist
sort of uh you know I would basically
say you've got a system which is
inherently
um backward looking but that selection
is much better at recognizing patterns
in that backward fashion so that they
apply to it is as if selection looks
forward even though we know that it
cannot
yes good
thoughts on this oh boy I don't know
um thoughts on this oldest living thing
and the mutations it allegedly uses to
protect itself have you seen this large
fungus in Michigan weighs 440 tons well
this is not a new result I mean I'm
certainly aware of the
Critter but
is there something new about how it
functions
this is from this is a article on
Gizmodo from uh 2018.
I'd have to remind myself if I ever knew
yeah
um
yeah I remember
this vaguely but I don't know anything
about it now I don't know if there's
anything new about it
um
Maybe
the militant moderate rights Sam Harris
would respond favorably to a steel man
off
an initial conversation to Simply nail
down what each of you thinks that
another conversation a week or two later
I mean I've offered the man a bunch of
different mechanisms to deal with this I
don't think he could possibly have a
structural objection because the
structure is open uh think the problem
is he is beginning to detect just how
his heuristic led him into terrible
danger and he's having trouble you know
if you're Sam Harris and you believe all
the things that he keeps saying about
the importance of the institutions
and the discovery that the institutions
have completely collapsed that they are
effectively like the rabid dog
um is a terrifying realization and I
don't disagree that it's terrifying but
I've been trying to tell people for
decades that that's where we were headed
and so this isn't new to me I'm less
terrified because I've gone through the
horrifying thought experiment of what
are we going to do if these institutions
stop working right so I think he's just
getting used to the idea and
um anyway you see some evidence that
it's getting used to the idea
I think the level at which he has ended
up wrong over the pandemic is going to
force him to realize
that some fundamental assumption has to
be off and he's going to discover that
the fundamental assumption is that
there's such a thing as experts and that
they work in institutions and that those
institutions are uh you know more right
than they are wrong and the answer is no
they're more advisor than they are
reality and
Pfizer isn't your friend
you know
it seems like a lot of assumptions
though it's going to be it's a big house
of cards
the man's got himself a house of cards
built on Sand and uh it ain't gonna last
especially with the coming storms so you
know I don't know how many analogies we
have to throw in there
to wake him up but Sam it's time
okay
in the last q a
oh
three weeks ago I don't remember uh this
this person is referring to a question
from the last command in the last q a I
meant that characteristic of religious
and psychedelic experience is the
dissolution of the boundary between self
and other
to what extent and in what circumstances
is selfhood or loss of it adaptive oh
I don't remember the question but I can
certainly proceed from that last bit
uh all right
there's a question about levels of
selection you will find in my opinion a
low quality version of that discussion
Under The Heading of group selection
a high quality version of that would
involve a recognition of lineage
selection and
the superior thing about a lineage level
analysis is that lineages
are legitimate targets of selection and
therefore appropriate loci for
adaptation
so that may sound
unnecessarily complex but the upshot is
our you an individual are lineage until
you have Offspring or other descendants
at which point you plus all of your
descendants are a lineage right
the focus that we critters have on us as
individuals has a lot to do with the
fact that our ability
to behave in ways that
favor our lineage going forward is
actually
historically very constrained
you have as much evolutionary interest
in the fate of your genes a thousand
Generations from now as you do the fate
of your genes in the Next Generation but
you have essentially no control over
their fate a thousand Generations from
now and you have a lot of control over
the next Generation so we have a vision
of the world that is
um biased in the direction of
individuality not because that's
evolutionarily more important but
because it's more tractable so
what I would say is some part of you
knows this some part of you understands
that you are simultaneously an
individual that has a Consciousness and
that you can affect things you know near
to you in space and time and some part
of you understands that that's Folly
it's a very temporary kind of effect and
that what really matters is the much
longer term stuff which you don't know
how to think about
when you
are participating in a thousand-year-old
tradition
it has built into it mechanisms that the
group selectionists and others might
call pro-social that is things that
cause you to think more in terms of your
lineage as well-being
and when you take entheogens you may
also tap into a kind of recognition you
know there is this ego death phenomenon
which Heather
alluded to and the fact is ego death the
experience of it is something like being
okay with your temporary
nature with your finite nature right and
it
to the extent that I'm in a position to
even say what it's like it does feel
like a tapping into the greater more
Global calculus rather than the narrow
individually focused calculus which is
so effective but distorted
um
so I do think that there's an analogy
between those two things right a ancient
tradition can
house and transmit between Generations a
more global view and likewise entheogens
that move the boundary of Consciousness
may allow you to tap into a sort of
deeper sense of where you are in the
universe and that may sound vague or it
may actually be a correct description
but I at least believe it
I feel like there's a lot more to say
there
I can't quite figure out what to say
um
to what degree do you think
there might be analogy between religious
and psychedelic experience I guess so
that's not the main thrust of this
question and I think you know you and I
don't have religious experience to to
compare to right uh to build on but I
think it's interesting that this isn't
the first time I've seen those two that
have invoked as as
at least analogous and maybe sharing
something even more than that sort of
accessing a uh a mental state
uh that sheds
that sheds light
uh and you know sometimes it's described
as actually a literal shedding of light
um onto
parts of yourself your individuality
your personhood that you didn't
otherwise have access to
well look I think
I think antheogens
at a literal level move the threshold of
consciousness
so that there's stuff taking place in
your mind that you don't have conscious
access to normally and that threshold
gets moved so suddenly you're conscious
so a lot of processes
that you wouldn't ordinarily be able to
tap into so like you can you can now
reflect inward on your own
on on into a deeper part of your brain
yeah into parts of your brain that have
a a utility but not or that are usually
your Consciousness is usually shielded
from them
and
there are two ways that that could and
in fact I bet you both of these are
right
um there are two ways in which you might
find a religiosity over that boundary
one of which
is that your culture no matter what
culture it is has a lot of religiosity
in its foundation even if you're in a
secular society it was built from a
religious society and so it might be
that there's a lot of stuff in the inner
workings of your culture which you don't
recognize as religious in nature but uh
that when you move that boundary you
suddenly tap into them and these are
things that you know would have come to
you
uh developmentally just by picking up
the culture around you but the other way
is that
you know shamanism
often has a hallucinogenic mode
and that is to say in order to bring
things into a religious framework within
a culture somebody and maybe more than
one somebody is encouraged to step into
that nebulous usually outside of
Consciousness layer and you know I've
always thought that they are allowed to
sort of report back what they see
and the nice thing about having that be
a shaman is that you can take it
seriously if it sounds right and you can
ignore it if it sounds like garbage and
you know so there's a facultative
relationship the shaman has understood
to be
otherworldly and
um you know
I you know look the experience of
hallucinogens is very insightful but at
least with many hallucinogens a lot of
it does not stand up to the
clear-headedness of the following day
right so the point is it's like a high
mutation rate way of thinking that
increases the amount of garbage and
increases the sensitivity to subtle
things that you might otherwise throw
out because they were swirling and
garbagey stuff
um
having a shaman which is thrilling yeah
just swirling um having a shaman who can
go there on behalf of a population and
then report back uh is kind of The Best
of Both Worlds right you don't want the
captain on hallucinogens right you want
uh somebody who can safely be sidelined
when need be and then listen to when
need be that's a that's a much more
ideal structure
but anyway yes I do think there's a
connection between religiosity and the
somewhat subconscious or outside of
conscious state that is accessed through
antigens
awesome
we have an extremely cuddly cat here
today oh yeah
James Lindsay has been doing
first of my own head yes I just heard
buzzing when I started speaking like it
was in the mic
that didn't happen it was all that talk
about in atheogens I I didn't hear it
okay so if it was in your own head then
the insulative layer on the outside kept
it from getting out yeah the dura
matcher kept it okay right James Lindsay
oh man
yeah I got it again maybe it's just
James Lindsay
hey Jim if you're watching
how are you doing man James Lindsay has
been doing a lot of good work lately on
the rot in education it'd be interesting
to see you talk to him about that on a
guest episode
it's a good idea yeah yeah
um
my wife one thing about having a really
cuddly cat in the spring is that there's
everywhere yeah
so much for
my wife is pregnant with our first and
our obstetrician recommended the TDOT
vaccine the third trimester do you have
thoughts on the risk benefit ratio for
this love the show thank you
well I don't remember so our boys are
going to be next month 19 and 17.
and I do not remember having recommended
any vaccines during pregnancy yeah I am
certain that I would have been shocked
at the suggestion that I receive
vaccines during pregnancy and obviously
the vaccine schedule for um for newborns
and for kids is extensive and um there's
been a lot of discussion there's a lot
more discussion to be had about
how much of that
um makes sense in the way it's currently
configured but
um
during pregnancy I would want to know a
lot about why that change happened
um under what kinds of conditions that
change happened and what the
justification for it is I would be my
default position would be no vaccines
during pregnancy no thank you yeah it's
hard to imagine that they could possibly
know enough
to be certain that this was uh more
beneficial than it is risky
um so anyway I'd be curious what the
thinking was but I let's just say
um complex systems within complex
systems being what they are
everybody's reflexive position
ought to be Extreme Caution intervening
in a system that works very well
um
yeah yeah
I'd I would be interested to know more
about this particular recommendation if
you can point us to something yeah
I've heard that some function I have
thousands of sexes if sex is the result
of gamete size and function what does
that tell us about their gametes
so I don't remember
much about what fungi are doing they
don't have
um
they have thousands of mating types
and
I don't remember I don't think it's
about a bunch of different gamete sizes
and and and mobilities so you know the
the anti-sogamy that plants animals have
uh two gametes two gamete types one of
which has the cytoplasm and as a result
of being large compared to the other one
then it tends to be sessile it's the egg
and one of them being stripped down has
none of the cellular Machinery except
for basically a haploid complement of um
of the genome and um and basically a
motor tail and that one's that one's
motile
um
fungi don't have gamete types that way
I don't think but I don't remember and
they're even they're even weirder
because they're so weird hello um if I
recall correctly and you know
it's a big Kingdom so there's a lot of
variation too some of them are only
breeding asexually some they're doing
both asexual and sexual well the thing
that I recall most profoundly was an
inversion of whether the single Feld
stage was
uh diploid or haploid
but that isn't that
I think I recall a haploid organism yes
uh with a single cell diploid stage or
something I feel like some plants may
even do that too maybe not I don't think
so okay but anyway I think the problem
is
a you've got a radical body is haploid
maybe it's very different it's so weird
but yeah
you have a
Kingdom that is so radically different
from the other multicellular kingdoms
and yet interestingly more closely
related to animals than either art
plants
but that fact
um causes us to do a mismapping
right I'm not sure you know mating types
and Sexes is not a particularly close
analogy right
um the whole life cycle is so distinct
that
I would just be very cautious about
being too aggressive about mapping what
we know from animals and plants onto
the fungus yeah I would I would love to
read you know even as much as a book but
I would prefer it if it was like a 20 to
30 page scholarly paper describing
what's going on with um reproduction in
fungi
um but I don't know if it's possible
even because there's so many different
things happening man he is on the move
today
um
regarding using their own tools against
them I think we need to start sex
affirming
however you decorate you are a beautiful
and unique male or female Perfect Just
As You Are
well thank you I like this
yes you are
um no this is this is this is good I
like this because we're being told
gender affirming and life-affirming
how does that it is used as a euphemism
for
affirming somebody's psychological sense
of being in the wrong body
okay maybe I I haven't heard that but
gender affirming which is the common
thing versus sex affirming yeah you know
what uh yeah there are people they're
increasingly I'm running into you know a
lot of us are just getting fed up like
pushed push push the limit like you know
what
yes I am less tolerant of the
than I was because it wasn't as
bullshitty before as it is now and it's
just pushed him too hard against too
many uh hard-won
um rights and laws and stop uh but
increasingly I am running into people
saying you know don't just don't talk
about gender at all gender isn't real
gender and sex is the same thing and
now I remember being
in
teaching
a class in a little Behavior class it's
got to be gosh 15 15 years ago maybe
um
and someone some students some female
student some you know lovely young woman
said something about well but isn't
gender such and such because you know I
did a lot I spent a lot of time in those
classes as you know talking about
evolution of sex evolution of sex role
sexual selection mating systems that was
a big chunk of what we did and uh oh but
isn't gender and I said sex gender is
the same thing I don't care
and she and she kind of got shocked and
I came back to her later and said I'm
you know I think I was too Brusque with
you
um I just I'm not interested in in that
distinction and that position of mine I
have changed because I thought
that um
you know maybe I was sort of presciently
understanding that gender was going to
be used as this weaponized thing
um but as you know you and I have come
to understand it at this point I think
it is a replacement for the term sex
role in other in other species where it
is um in animals effectively the
behavioral manifestation of how one
enacts the sex that they are
and in humans there is so much liability
there's so much plasticity in terms of
you know how it is that we we can act uh
that the way that we behaviorally
manifest while there are you know more
female typical or more male typical
things that we might do you can
definitely be act don't step on the
computer
um you can act uh more male typical and
and be female and that doesn't say
anything about
um you being born in the wrong body or
you know anything right so gender is
both real and distinct from sex
and so gender affirming
why do you need to just be who you are
that's cool be who you are and then sex
affirming and that is
actually what you were born as and that
wasn't assigned
by anything except the sperm that made
you into whom you are when it joined
with the egg that also made you into who
you were so I think
um this this points to a very important
hell of the gender affirming crowd
they're very interested in affirming
gender when it is in conflict with sex
and not interested at all in affirming
gender when it is consistent with sex
which it almost always is yeah um so
anyway whether we deal with this as sex
affirming or geez you know as long as
we're on the topic of gender affirming
do you realize how often it is that
one's gender actually matches what their
obstetrician thought it was going to
based on uh rather almost always
unambiguous characteristics that imply
things about uh chromosomes and most
importantly gamete size right so the
fact that they want to affirm it only in
those very very rare cases is indicative
that this is a dishonest argument to
begin with yes it's true absolutely
in 2021
even Trump derangement syndrome people
accepted lab leak after Jon Stewart made
it into a joke with that explosion of
chocolatey goodness near Hershey
Pennsylvania okay but he did on The
Colbert Show
um this is the scramble
run out the clock talking loudly
I think that last sentence is um a
directive like we should all run out the
clock talking lab leak or I'm not sure
well I'm not sure I do think the hmm
the fact there's still no evidence for a
natural origin and I literally mean this
there is no evidence for a natural
origin right there's lots of stuff that
is claimed to be evidence of some kind
that does not stand up to scrutiny
there's a ton of evidence in favor of
lab leak which doesn't mean lab leak is
true and natural origin is false but
every month we go without finding an
intermediate host
the less likely it is that we will ever
find one because there's ever less
likelihood that it actually exists so
anyway what we've got is under any
normal circumstances a slam dunk case
does that mean that it couldn't be
undone of course not you we could prove
that the Earth doesn't go around the sun
it's always open to a falsification
but am I expecting us to find out that
the Earth doesn't go around sun nope I
think it's more likely that we will find
a natural origin for SARS cov2 then we
will find that the Earth does not go
around the Sun but I don't think it's
likely right
it's a pretty good again you're just
going full Nuance on us today well I
guess I am
um but anyway the point is this is just
it is an unnatural level of reanimation
of this wrong idea yeah right and the it
is the unnatural level the two standards
right no amount of evidence is strong
enough for certain people to accept lab
leak as a strong possibility and no
level of weakness or absence of evidence
is enough to put this other hypothesis
even on pause it just continues to show
up yeah right and that's indicative of
this not being a scientific discussion
yep indeed
hello
has there ever been a species that
decreased its cognitive ability as it
evolved
if not why is it happening to humans
half joking
um I believe that we do have a case
and I believe actually there are
probably if you if you I mean look we've
got all sorts of interesting cases of
things like
this is not a cognitive case but it's
sort of a proof of concept of loss of
complexity and Nuance there are mites
which have had a deletion of a
developmental stage where they become
featureless in one of their stages I
recall that from from grad school right
um
there's lots of Developmental craziness
around metamorphosis or like oh actually
you had complete metamorphosis now you
have incomplete you had you know now you
have direct developments yeah like okay
so then the case that I would point to
as pretty close to a slam dunk okay are
the hobbits of Flores Island
where you have a radical decrease in
stature we have something these are Homo
floresciensis so congeners of humans
closely related maybe sister
probably a descendant of some homo
erectus yeah that existed on Flores
Island until very recently is that the
timing descendant of homo erectus that's
well that's invaded okay and there are
those people
um I call them those who are wrong
believe that the diminutive status may
be indicative of a pathology and
explanation that makes no sense but
nonetheless there's nothing in their
skeleton that suggests pathology except
they're short right it's really not I
mean the microcephaly the whole
pathology argument just does not stand
up to any scrutiny but and put that
aside appears to be something like a
homo erectus we have another case which
is in my opinion less clear but also
interesting
right where you also have diminutive
status diminutive status theatric
stature that's what I mean yeah
um but the point is I mean they're dead
so they've got diminished status as well
yes especially yes especially in the
last
many Millennia but
um so I keep interrupting you but Flores
is an island a little island in um
Indonesia yeah and what we have is a
population of descendants of something
that we call a human ancestor you could
get into the nuances of this but uh
something like a homo erectus who came
through
um Indonesia left a population on Flores
Island they became dwarfed as species
often do on Islands
the diminutive population hunted
diminutive elephants tegadon elephants
the size of a cow right so you had
people three foot tall people hunting
elephants the size of a cow collectively
um but they had a radically decreased
cranial volume and while Cranium will
not radically reduced for their size
right they were proportionally reduced
right they were
um so that does not and it's not a slam
dunk of the question of did they have
diminished cognitive capacity because
there are some subtleties you know you
cognitive cranial capacity and cognitive
capacity are not synonymous they ought
to be related because
to the extent that selection could
decrease the size of a brain and retain
all of the cognitive capacity it would
be strongly incentivized to do that
because the brain is very expensive and
vulnerable and it's also it poses a
terrific risk in childbirth to have such
a big head right both of those things to
grow and run and sometimes kills your
mom and then you're going to be dead too
so lots of reasons to have a smaller
head if we could so the answer to why
selection why cognitive capacity and
brain size are not more closely related
than they turn out to be is a good one
and it's worth exploring but a
substantial decrease in the size of a
cranium from the homo erectus standard
to the Flores Island standard
suggests a decrease in something we'll
get to that something some other day
maybe but
um but that does suggest that this does
happen in circumstances where the payoff
for that cognitive capacity is lower now
in our circumstance it's pretty obvious
what's going on
the decrease in our cognitive capacity
isn't to decrease in
mental horsepower at a neurological
level it is the chaos of the
developmental noise in our
hyper novel world where things are
changing so quickly that nobody knows
what the smart things to continue to
believe are
so anyway yeah I think it's a very
different phenomenon it's a rapid change
and everybody's confused and that's
making the kids more confused than the
adults who were confused to begin with
and uh so it goes
okay two more questions and then we'll
wrap it up for today
how do we get back to raising butchering
and selling our critters locally
that's well
that is going to be a very uh location
specific
answer I think because there are there
are places where people are doing this
um I think we're going to be forced to
it those of us who are cognizant of the
dangers of novelty and Hyper novelty
you know to the extent that the same
mechanisms that allowed Pharma to not
only bypass the normal regulatory
mechanism but get government to mandate
mRNA transfection into large numbers of
people they are going to pull the same
stunt with respect to
veterinary medicine
and livestock right so those of us who
are aware of how dangerous that is are
certainly going to be incentivized if
you weren't pushed by
um you know industrial agriculture to
Source organic
food
the you know Brave New World of
new modifications are going to push a
lot of those people
who were skeptical into the actually I
actually want a real animal that hasn't
been messed with
um and how am I going to get that and so
anyway I do think we're about to see
um
we're about to see much more aggressive
technology pushed into our food supply
which is going to cause a larger number
of people to reject it all together and
embrace traditional foods and I mean we
we saw
we saw back to the farm movements
a movements when we saw several versions
of back to the farm movements uh when we
were at Evergreen there were there was
an organic farm on campus and there were
some both ecoag programs and food
programs that were quite good you know
really excellent and we had a number of
students who became Farmers temporarily
mostly and
um
and learned a tremendous amount about
the food security and soil health and
terroir and and such and you know I
think
you know even even just farmers markets
experienced a Resurgence in the U.S
after
um becoming something that sort of mid
20th century a lot of people were sold
basically you know a bill of goods by
Procter and Gamble and all the other you
know these these big food producing
outfits that convinced you that
convinced a lot of people a lot of um a
lot of women buying food for their
families that the safest way to feed
your family was to have it have been
sterilized and prepared by um you know a
company far far away and you should buy
it in a supermarket rather than ever
getting it from you know The Grubby
hands of a farmer but you know even by
the time you know we were
um
by the time we were in grad school in
the 90s
um there was there was much more
Resurgence in that regard and I you know
I've pointed people there before but um
go you know check out subscribe to slow
down Farmstead slow down Farmstead on
substack uh where Tara Couture writes uh
an extraordinary number of
posts about her and her family's journey
through at this point they are in in
Ontario
mostly growing only for themselves but
this year in in Canada they are eating a
hundred percent food that they
themselves have grown produced so
amazing accomplishment amazing right and
for years they've been doing 85 to 90
percent but just like Canada we're
talking like no lemons
you know no uh no vanilla no you know no
coffee
um chocolate right this like it just
there's a tremendous amount of things
that um that even those of us who think
we're eating consciously and carefully
are just you just have no idea yeah
um and and actually one of her recent
posts maybe even today
um talks about some of the journey from
you know having been buying from people
who are raising their own cows and
buying half a cow and you know having a
chest freezer to put it in here this is
something that that we've we've been
doing for a long time but
you know creating those networks of
um with people
who uh
oh share your values and see the same
things that you do and therefore you can
and and you know maybe you're not the
person who's growing the
sheep or the cows or maybe you are and
you need to earn money to do other
things in your life or you have you are
doing other things in your life you're
not going to be growing them but you
have the money to spend on the excellent
Quality Meat like find those people and
make those connections and um and that
that will be one of the ways that we
that we have a chance of emerging from
this intact yep the tragedy of course is
that uh to the extent that there is a
Dawning awareness of what's good for you
and what isn't it is of course the
people with more resources that have
access to the good food and
um will make it last for the people who
are already uh at a disadvantage yeah I
mean food food desert is a an overly
simplistic description
um
you know fixing fixing the food desert
problem uh would largely mean bringing
in you know the ability to find those
those processed foods that also aren't
very good for you yeah um and you know
yeah we're a long way from from getting
real honest amazing food to everyone who
which used to be eating it
okay one last question
how might I get my mother to peek inside
my media bubble
she won't discuss the trans Michigan
that's how I pronounce it right yeah I'm
just how you pronounce it she won't
discuss the transmission Goss with me
and seems at least partially race woke
yeah that's a tough question uh I've
been talking to multiple people about
the possibility
that next gen social media would
inherently involve the ability to peer
through anybody else's eyes right how
useful would it be if you could click a
button and you could see the feed as if
you were somebody with whom you don't
get along right
um
it obviously doesn't really exist now I
think there's far too little
emphasis on understanding even what the
algorithms are that are causing us to
derange right you there ought to be an
obsession with reverse engineering those
algorithms so that you can correct for
them and there's very little attention
paid people are aware of the algorithms
but they have so far not attempted to
figure out how to unmake them yeah but
anyway uh maybe maybe Elon Musk will
build this into Twitter so that we can
look through each other's eyes and I
believe that that would actually bring
us much closer together
but that's a long ways away and so how
to help an individual
share some of what
he or she is seeing
um
to begin to
the program that's maybe not the right
word but to help awaken
the mom to uh to some of what
he's saying
um
I don't I don't think we can do this
generically I think
we don't know all we know about you is
that you're paying enough attention to
have written us a question yeah and to
have used the word michigas here so
um
you know you know who you are and what
your relationship with your mother is
and what and who she is more than
um you know doesn't want to talk trans
and maybe partially race woke you also
have a have some sense of where she is
getting her media feeds and also you
know why she might be resistant you know
does she have a group of friends
with whom she will not be able to hang
out anymore if she starts thinking
different things
and is are those is that group of
friends the thing that is the most
important
thing in her life in which case it's
going to be really really hard
uh if she is resistant because uh you
know we don't think that way in this
family and you say well you know I do
and um actually this is to me consistent
with
um the way I've always thought and I
think that we are being told that this
new way of thinking is you know fill in
the blank liberal
um you know compassionate whatever and I
think it's actually the opposite and
here's why then you know that that I
feel like you do have a chance of of
conveying some of what you see is the
reality but if there's a social barrier
it's much harder
yeah although it does suggest a partial
answer may or may not work in your case
but
the thing that people fear is being
outed to those you know presumably to
those in their world who will be least
tolerant of it and to the extent that
you know your mom should be prioritizing
her relationship
with you but it may be that you're
tolerant enough that you'll put up with
the Michigan and her friends won't put
up with reality
um so one thing you might do
is figure out how to offer safety that
you and your mom can talk about reality
and that it doesn't
result in her being outed as a hypocrite
to people whose Viewpoint she has
prioritized
that's good
all right
we've arrived
we will
be back next week
in the meantime please subscribe like
share
share with people who you think will
appreciate it consider sharing with
people that you're not sure well and see
what happens
it's it's the way that we start
conversations is by
um saying things or sharing things that
were not positive in advance are going
to be well received and seeing what
happens and surprising often
how well things are received when we
weren't expecting it
so until we see you next time which will
be the same time same place next week
we could do the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]